[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
wonderful episode of the careful boys we
have with us the cash flow doctor eric
here's me
and as a bonus we got chris over there
okay eric speaking as a financial expert
and i hope it's not too late for me to
be asking this but with the recession
and everything what do we do
man and what is a recession how are we
gonna make it and what is really
happening right now that's a great
question are we yeah are we in one how
do we know well according to the fed you
know
not really but yeah we are i feel like
every year they say we're in a [ __ ]
recession yeah is that true so let's
first talk about what the technical
definition of a recession is so
technical definition of it is
two consecutive quarters where you have
constrained gdp growth instead of it
going positive it's going negative for
two quarters
so quarter two of 2022
that were in 2022 had a loss and they're
predicting that the upcoming quarter
quarter three is going to be a loss as
well because of inflation all this stuff
what about quarter one is that a growth
or quarter one was actually if i recall
correctly i think it was like flat so
we're we're on the verge of recession so
we need a third quarter to figure out
which direction it's going so that's
that's a technical definition but the
challenge with that is the the
it depends on how you look at it from
either quarterly or monthly because you
might have had let's say january and
february
the gdp technically during those months
were up and then the last month was down
right so if you're doing it from quarter
core perspective your variation might
shift so there's there's two sides if
you have the technical side and that's
what all the news pundits are talking
about but that's not entirely accurate
we want to look at it from a monthly
perspective now from uh from a general
like macro economic side of things i
personally feel and like a lot of other
economists feel like we've been we've
already been in a recession for a little
bit so the whole nature of this whole
two quarters in a row
reduced gdp growth
are we officially in a recession are we
starting it now i think we've already
had it and we've already been inside of
it
right so i don't know if that answers
that question but i a lot of us feel
this yeah
yeah pretty much they've been they've
been lying yeah
but they told us it was retract like
what was it like it was transitional
like the the the inflation's not a thing
like it just trans you just print money
it's trying to transitory transitory
transitory transitory inflation so
that's that's the second facet of it
which is kind of dynamic and that our
situation right now is very different
than previous recessions so i've been an
entrepreneur
and i lost everything in the 2001
recession i lost everything in the 2008
recession so i've lived through a couple
of these and
you know i kind of have a little skin
under my teeth from like these different
recessions right but like this one's a
little bit different from those previous
two
right the first one in 2001 was when he
had the dot-com bubble it imploded 911
happened a whole bunch of things
happened and it caused this whole
recession to happen and then 2008 was
different that was the whole mortgage
crisis
where they're providing loans to people
that didn't qualify for that's the short
right for loans right and then you had
these big financial companies really
going under this one's very different
especially with inflation right now so
we
right now we feel inflation is high and
we believe in inflation size because gas
is high
rents high
the rent's too damn high let's go
[ __ ] pizzas 50 cents more the chicken
fake is now 4.99 oh yeah criminal man
man but arizona iced tea 129
right is it 129.
it went up even though it says 99 cents
on the bottle or the can no they are
staunch defenders of inflation um i
thought that that stuff was a bad sign
maybe this is the chinese market
but but there are challenges right this
is not our traditional inflation we have
this huge amount of money that was
printed two years ago in 2020 and then
on top of that too there is some
transitory issues our supply chain is
still disrupted because of covet
gas prices did spike and they are
starting to come back down again thank
goodness which is really nice come back
down to [ __ ] six dollars
it makes six dollars make good look it
look good like oh yes perfect
six dollars amazing are they coming back
down because of is that good news or are
they coming back down because of
something bad that they're doing like
are they just printing more money or
you know there's this is a very complex
situation and the challenge with it is
is us as humans we want to simplify
things so sometimes people have
conspiracy theories sometimes we listen
to news folks that try to boil this
complex situation down into biden or
trump or whatever you can't really do
putin right you really can't do that
it's super complicated yeah right so we
have we have food issues and food supply
chain issues and some people have this
conspiracy theory oh they're burning
down these food supply things to
create a square fighter and cause
scarcity but the reality is like in
global markets right now
we have a very tight supply chain and
what we've realized is we've we've lived
in as we call just in time model of
production thanks to toyota thanks
toyota yeah toyota created it tune us
over and the challenge of that is it's a
very lean production model which
in bull market times is good because
they're you're running as lean as
possible maximizing profit margins
you're only producing things when you
need it but the problem is if one little
cog breaks in that system you're [ __ ]
right so we're seeing it in automotive
one little company that makes a chip
disrupts the entire porsche
production
right and you see in the food space and
the food side of things you you have
ukraine which is the biggest bread
basket of europe they can't ship their
grain out because of what's happening
with ukraine and russia
and russia recently signed a
an agreement that allowed ukraine to ex
finally export their grain and then
russia the next day they bombed the port
right so we have these issues and the
challenge with it is like
technically the world is making more
food than the entire world can consume
so from a global perspective you're like
how's this one country [ __ ] us all up
but the challenges you have to remember
like supply chain is very fragile right
now like if you had grain in the us and
we're one of the biggest exporters of
rain it's very hard for us to ship grain
overseas and when we do that instead of
like countries like countries inside of
africa
being able to get it from local areas
and they have this small shipping cost
now if they bring it in from the u.s you
have to add in the shipping you have to
add in the profit margin you have to add
all these things it causes food costs to
go up so you have this like this
compounding thing and the challenge that
we have as as americans we see things
from a perspective of this is just
happening in america so it's biden or
trump or whatever the news is saying it
is yeah but this is a global spouchy
voucher
in this mask
he's about to retire he's about to just
like finish it up after this after this
turn his mic drop was the recession dude
that was a [ __ ] man [ __ ] fouchy he's
like i cheated i'm ouchy without [ __ ]
she's ouchy as regular citizens seeing
all this happen yeah what can we do to
stay afloat like is there any
yeah so i i honestly think there's just
two ways to look look at it and we were
chatting about this earlier right we
have this
we have this kind of like um conundrum
of thrift
so here's kind of the thing normally
when we hear the word recession it
strikes fear into a lot of folks so
you're starting to see
and i see it as an accountant we work
with a lot of enterprise level companies
we work a lot of nft companies all the
stuff the moment the word recession was
spit out everyone stopped hiring
everyone stopped expanding everyone
stopped trying to build things because
they're like we just need to tighten up
the ropes right so that's normally
what's going to happen is all of us feel
concerned that
we need to save more money just in case
for the rainy day and that is important
to do but there is this conundrum of
thrift because in the u.s
the whole idea of the the recession is
based on what we call two quarters of
gross domestic product or gdp
and gdp is
the us the vast majority of gdp is
produced through consumption
so if we as americans
save and we don't spend
what does that do to gross domestic it
keeps going down it keeps going down
right thank you teacher right and then
i was gonna say it first they paid
attention economically so proud of you
so proud
so like if you think of it right like it
creates us like this this this cycle
where people are spending less and then
that means companies like [ __ ] we need
to make less stuff
and oh we don't need as much payroll so
let's let people go
and now there's less people that's able
to consume and it creates this cycle
right so
from at least from my perspective
i think it's very important for all of
us to to look at paying down consumer
debt to look at purchasing items that
are essential to our household what's
consumer debt just like all of our own
credit cards pay our own credit cards
off if you can right like or or at least
cut down on
expenditures that are non-essential
right because at the end of the day it's
like the more liquid capital you have
the better off you'll be and i work with
a lot of investors too and right now i'm
telling a lot of the investors that are
in our practice this is a really good
time to just stack cash
even though it may constrain the
recovery because what's going to happen
is as a recession goes on people are
going to fire sale assets and it's a
great way of
investing back into the market right and
a lot of wealth is created in recessions
and this is a normal thing like that the
reality is in the economy we have booms
and we have bus this is very
normal right these are cyclical things
that happen so the more we can prepare
ourselves and just at least understand
the risks that are out there like i
wouldn't be in a position of taking
larger risks without doing more research
right for example like i'm still like in
my company i'm still expanding i'm still
hiring because i see there's a lot of
need for the tax and the accounting side
of things but in general terms like for
most folks a lot of folks that might be
listening into this
i would highly recommend to start
thinking about
spending less on things that you don't
really need
right still live life still enjoy life
still do your things but like if you're
deciding on buying a
4 000 louis vuitton bag
when you don't really need a louis
vuitton bag maybe hold on to that cash
for a bit longer just smash and grab
like whatever that's a good idea
we'll just do that
in california you're not going to get in
trouble for it
yeah they'll let you go
yeah yeah we're seeing that behavior too
because i think netflix just announced
they lost a million subscribers yeah
that's huge so i think people are kind
of like checking their own uh
where they're spending their money and
then like oh maybe i don't need like 20
things maybe i only like hulu or amazon
prime or whatever so i think yo i've
been spending bread on these
subscriptions how much if you just add
them all up yo at least
over 200 on on subscriptions yo i mean i
got all of them bro i got netflix and
pornhub premium youtube huh pornhub
premium and only found a premium no i
don't have i don't have any of those
those accounts my cheats but yeah you
know yeah ip's gonna sign it at the same
time
yeah yeah but yeah canceling i mean just
looking at those alone and then even
like oh food eating out oh my gosh the
worst he now will get you so you said
you were that's a need for me yeah
me too premium oh both it's a it's a
life it's a it's a life force yeah
watching pornhub at cheesecake
[Laughter]
so you said
having been through the 2001 yeah and
the 2008 do you feel like this one we're
currently in is comparatively worse or
is it not as bad
i think it's a little bit worse
i was just hoping you wouldn't
why do you think it's a word
i think like let's use the word worse in
a subjective framing let's give a little
bit more context to this right like the
challenges that we have now are
multitude things we we're living in a
much more globally interconnected
society right like where people are
realizing even avian england they're
realizing the whole concept of
nationalization and doing the brexit was
flipped it didn't work for them it's
costing them about 42 or 45 billion
dollars for that one decision and we
don't know that we're very
interconnected as a society where in
2008 2001 we weren't as much
right so they they always say when
america sneezes the world catches a cold
right so we are we do have a set of
global challenges that are very
different
and in terms of the recession we're
looking at things more than just as
economics right now
if we're looking at food shortages
around the world
especially in these three world
countries what do you think led on this
onset of terrorism and people wanting to
attack all these other countries it was
hunger lack of opportunity all these
things and we're starting to get into
this macroeconomic situation where these
countries are again going to be facing
lack of food have hunger starvation all
these things people want to get mad
again it's going to cause like a rise in
potentially terrorism or instability
globally
so in terms of the recession like i kind
of feel like we can recover
you know get out of it in 12 to 18
months it's typically the average of a
lengthy recession 12 to 18 months to
kind of get out of it and start
recovering again but i think we're going
to have a lot of other global issues
that are going to come from this
particular thing and all from
covet and valcine who would have known
that
this fragile supply chain who would have
known that this fragile supply chain
that we have to maximize profits and i
love capitalism like i'm an entrepreneur
but that the capitalist system that
we've built has been very fragile we've
been focused purely on maximizing profit
without creating sustainability
and it's gonna [ __ ] us up right we're
gonna have to grow out of this or figure
this out wow
it definitely definitely doesn't feel
like we're on the up and up with things
yeah you know what i'm saying so you
saying this isn't really a surprise it's
like the last like couple years days of
just i mean i mean especially dealing
with this pandemic so definitely it
doesn't feel like we're this is going to
come out all
sunshines and rainbows and stuff it's
like
it's like every restaurant you drive by
it's like now hiring now
and it's like dude i didn't know that
there's all these jobs that couldn't be
filled which is weird because in a
recession you think there's not enough
jobs yeah yeah but then it's like
there's
so many places yeah i saw a [ __ ]
burger king it was like we'll give you a
sign-on bonus and this and i was like
for burger king dude makes me want to go
work yeah
yeah king taco has like a was like a 15
hour starting yeah damn king taco
and benefits
it's just like what uh andy nguyen was
saying about how he couldn't get after
staffed enough because people didn't
want to work so shout out to everybody
who is still working a job that they
don't have to do
respect for that for sure yeah
absolutely so it's we definitely have a
very unique global macro economic
situation so for those of you guys
listening in i think the biggest things
to kind of start thinking about now is
maybe put off
luxury purchases maybe
start considering paying down credit
card debts you don't have this like
ongoing debt right because as they start
raising interest rates
the credit card debt is also going to go
up because usually it's prime rate plus
a percentage right so you want to make
sure that you have that under control
start making sure you have some rainy
day funds set aside have some extra
liquid cash right so if something was to
happen if you got laid off or whatever
you have some capital to get you through
the challenges most people live paycheck
to paycheck because again we have this
consumerist consumption society yeah i
mean i have amazon boxes show up my
house all the time and i'm like do i
really need this
whatever it is i ordered yeah probably
sometimes sometimes it's necessary
it's a good deal every time i buy
anything on amazon
because i'm a person of convenience
i always get three right
on my office three tires
he gets three times
tires even though you need four
yeah no cut it down you know i [ __ ] i
need batteries
and then i don't even go look at my
battery box the amount of batteries i
just ordered three of them and it comes
in i'm like all right cool got my
batteries and then when i go put them
away i see that i already had a stack of
[ __ ] three bags
so when the world comes to an end we're
all going to bartend yeah oh no for sure
all of them are probably expired already
because i'm not even using them i just
keep adding new ones on top
even your gun
safe that big you know what's a funny a
weird uh paradox too is that
you start to reclassify which things are
luxury
right and like things that you got used
to during the pandemic like ordering
food is now a luxury which is odd
because it's like i got so used to
postmating but actually that costs way
more postmates ruin the economy i think
yeah
you said it was great but i think it's
mostly postman it's like personal
economy
that's uber lyft
dude
during cove though i feel like uh
postmate postmating so much was kind of
justified right because you're like yeah
i don't want to interact yeah yeah yeah
this is the safest way and then like and
then jill's at home yelling at me like
do you really need to spend 15 bucks on
boba i'm like yes i do
because my mental health is just as
important as physical health you don't
want to go off
yourself
you got to stay in the house
that's what they tell me what's what she
says
so there's this one part of economic
theory from so there's this famous
economist called keynesian that's his
last name and he has this one part of
his theory called the animal spirit and
like what does animal spirit have to do
with economics but that's all about the
psychology of it right when people are
in fear or when they're in greed
dictates the or the the length of how
long it takes to recover from something
so the moment that the word recession
gets spitted around everyone is in fear
and everyone's constraining
so until there is a situation or there
is like uh some sort of a trend where
people feel confident again we're going
to keep going down a rabbit hole or a
stagnation of growth
right so the people need to feel like
stable or something before it starts
going back up and that's that's a
challenge that we've had ever since code
the technology like that the challenge
with that is like we've been in very
unstable times for the last i don't know
four years between the last
administration this administration both
administrations not knowing what's going
on the economic situation covid do we
wear masks do we get vaccines all these
different things it's created this level
of instability or inherent fear that
also dictates and determines how people
spend and how they consume
right so a lot of things beyond just the
printing of money a lot of a lot of
things beyond just the supply chain
right it's like this human dynamic which
is crazy what do you think about
investments right now you're know people
they're like right now is the cheapest
time to buy stocks crypto real estate
whatever you think like in a recession
is a good time to start buying some
things because they are like at the
lowest
i mean the the idea or the notion that
we're at the lowest is very subjective
like and again not financial advice do
your own research
um but i've spoken to and i've interact
with a couple of very wealthy folks even
a couple of billionaires and they're all
just sitting with dry powder on the side
to buy in because they're like it's not
the lowest it's not the lowest yeah
right we still have a lot of things that
need to happen we've had a market that's
done very well in the last couple of
years including because of all this
growth of the money supply that needs to
have a correction that needs to have a
calming down again it's that that boom
and bust cycle so we're probably
somewhere in the middle of the halfway
down to the bus cycle
that's what i was going to ask is like
the last one it was clear the last
recession because everyone there was a
domino effect and a stock market tank
and then like where a lot of the homes
went like you know foreclosed and stuff
and then people lost jobs and then
like because i was a graduate in 2009
and i couldn't get a job anywhere
because no like all the places that
we're hiring it was taken over by over
qualified dudes that got laid off of
their jobs so they were doing the
entry-level college kid jobs some dude
that might so my dad's a car dealer at
commerce casino a dude with a phd
applied to be a dealer during that time
i'd probably be probably because it was
an anthropology phd
useless
my dad was laughing and he was like man
i [ __ ] came here to container we got
the same job
hell yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you